you can definitely help her
i would like a roll like that but i
find the word for it really difficult
to pronounce
can you tell me we means this
was it they are exactly sunflowers
not a roll they
are so delicious but the word means
so much silver for so long  find it really
difficult flecks
you should say it again slower
kern bun
[music]
probably something like that that's right
and maybe that's because
the word for it is so difficult
to pronounce because help further
that's a matchstick layer a
really nice straight difficult  so
this munich
for me it's an advantage that i
can't tell me what this
number is called 555 that you really have
the number maybe five times
in a row 555 555 555 555
55 right to start but for you
not really very well many  thanks to
stockholm, the match against hrbaty is in
germany,
that's what i thought and you know how it is
there  s means that's a squeaky
ducky that's pronounced nicely do you think
that turned out to be difficult no so if
you're native german it's
actually not that difficult to
pronounce
[music]